Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail number
and that number is two one nine two. David
P. As many of you know, I've been saying for
since the start of the Kyle Rittenhouse trial,
I believe not guilty will be the verdicts. And
I got a very strange voicemail over the weekend
saying that I was so wrong about the case that I
should expect to be sued by whom. I don't know,
but take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hey, PAC boy,
I just wanted to let you know that you
were wrong about Rittenhouse, after all.
And I bet you're ready for the
lawsuits that are coming up. OK,
so those polls that are showing Trump
being inviting are not bogus. They are
true because Biden is just as dumb as you are by.
Speaker 1: This is a weird voicemail because the
caller seems to think I've said the opposite of
what I've said. I've said since the start of the
trial. I expect not guilty based on Wisconsin law
and the evidence, and that's what we got. I don't
know who would sue me or for what. And I didn't
say that the polls showing Trump beating Biden
are bogus. I said the pollster is not a
historically reliable pollster, Rasmussen.
But I also said I think the general message
that in a rematch of 2020 and 2024 Trump wins
is accurate. So as usual, criticize me for
things I've said. Is that too much to ask?
Not for things you imagine, I said, or you heard
on some other channel or you wish I had said,
or you misheard? I said, Criticize me
for things. I've said, Guys, please.
We've got a great bonus show for you today. I will
tell my Thanksgiving stories. Producer Pat will
tell his Thanksgiving stories. I expect his will
be more interesting because he was in Colombia,
not Columbia University, the country, Colombia,
where you know the our caller Pedro from Colombia,
where he's supposedly from. So Pat will tell us
those stories. We're also going to talk about
this latest attempt where conservatives. How do
they want to get books banned and the way they do
it is they organize to attack specific libraries
in the United States, not physically attack to
start sending in mass communication,
demanding certain books be removed
to make it seem like wow grassroots effort
from parents here to remove certain books.
This is the next sort of battle line in the
continued culture war, which is activating to
get certain books banned from American libraries.
We'll tell you who is doing it, where it's being
done, et cetera, et cetera. Sign up right now
at join Packman dot com to get access to the
world famous bonus show. We will see you then.
It's great to be back and will be here all week.